depuis l'arrivée de l'épidémie sur le
sol français son nom est sur toutes les
lèvres
dès le début de la crise du coït 19
l'infectiologue controversé didier
rahout préconise l'usagé de la
chloroquine en médicaments antipaludéens
très vite ses prises de position
tranchées divise la communauté
scientifique et sa personnalité divise
l'opinion
didier rahout doit alors faire face à
une vaste polémique allant même jusqu'à
recevoir des insultes et des menaces de
mort pas de quoi décourager le
professeur marseillais qui a toujours
campé sur ses positions
comme il devrait le faire ce mercredi
devant la commission parlementaire en
charge de déterminer les responsabilités
dans la gestion de la crise une
commission qui a d'ailleurs entendu
jérôme salomon et agnès buzyn et non les
auditions montrent déjà de graves
défaillances dans la gestion de
l'épidémie
sous ce que dénonce didier rahout les
politiques et leur décision c'est
l'histoire qui les juge
on verra très vite ce qu'il en est pour
cette crise on connaîtra la vérité
il y aura une enquête parlementaire
après tout ça et elle sera sanglante
alors que le chef de l'état s'est
déplacé en personne pour le rencontrer à
marseille zira hoult n'a pas hésité à
claquer la porte du conseil scientifique
des manuels macron je n'ai pas deux
heures à perdre dans des discussions qui
ne vont pas à l'essentiel
ce qui m'importe c'est de soigner les
malades pas les causeries où il ne faut
surtout froisser personne indifférent
honneur le professeur out est aussi
habitué des critiques sur son expertise
quand le 22 mai sa proposition
d'utiliser l'hydroxyde chloroquine est
remise en question par une étude parue
dans la célèbre revue médicale zealand 7
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
décide de suspendre les essais cliniques
avec cette molécule
en france le ministre de la santé se
saisit lui aussi très rapidement des
conclusions de cette étude pour annoncer
sa décision suite à la publication dans
zil handset d'une étude alertant sur
l'inefficacité et les risques de
certains traitements du coc vite 10,9
dont l'idh roxy chloroquine j'ai saisi
le haut conseil de la santé publique
pour qu'ils analysent et me propose sous
48 heures une révision des règles
dérogatoires de prescription alors qu'on
pensait le débat clos
coup de théâtre le 2 juin avec la
publication de ce communiqué du land 7
nous publions une expression
d'inquiétude pour alerter les lecteurs
sur le fait que de sérieuses questions
scientifiques
ont été portés à notre attention dans la
foulée de ce rétropédalage l' oms
annonce alors immédiatement la reprise
des essais cliniques et olivier vers ans
se voit obligé de demander des comptes à
la revue médicale
se pose alors plusieurs questions le
ministre de la santé est il allé trop
loin
peut-on parler de choix politiques
certains vont même plus loin olivier
ferrand et s'il le ministre de la santé
oms celui des lobbys l'hydroxyde du
rocking ou de quat'sous et j'ai très
peur que l'on veuille éliminer ce
médicament au profit d'un médicament qui
sera peut-être le même mais qui coûtera
beaucoup plus cher
au-delà des désaccords politiques ou
scientifique c'est aussi la personnalité
du professeur out qui fait débat raul
n'est pas une personnalité totalement
simple donc ça un petit peu pollué le
débat
il est vrai que ses apparitions dans les
médias ne passe pas inaperçu désir out
conserve pourtant beaucoup de soutien
voire même de vrais fans à marseille
notamment où certains lui voue une
admiration hors du commun
un jeune homme est même allé jusqu'à se
faire tatouer le visage du professeur
sur la jambe figure anticonformiste en
quelques mois le professeur out est
devenue une icône pour de nombreux
français et malgré les critiques il
persiste et signe elle la crise que le
pays vient de traverser est la
conséquence directe des choix politiques
et financiers de ces trente dernières
années